Coco the gorilla is a remarkable animal
who was taught American sign language
penny started teaching Coco as a baby
and the project continued into a
lifelong learning experience for
everyone involved by teaching Coco over
two thousand words she has been given
the power to communicate with humans it
has given us a glimpse into the actual
thoughts and desires of another species
Coco asked for a pet kitten after being
fascinated with a book about them
she named her first kid an all ball and
later when he was hit by a car we see a
reaction of non-human grief not too far
away from being human in the search for
a mate Coco was even able to join in the
age of digital dating and choose her own
match from a collection of videos
one moment that struck me was when they
bought in Coco's choice of mate and Coco
asked to break the usual protocol of
playing in adjacent yards for a few
weeks she asked to meet her new friend
straightaway there was a contrast
between what humans think is best for
animals and what the animals really want
it makes me wonder what else we get
wrong or don't understand there are many
things that I wish we could ask Coco
what answer would she give to the
meaning of life I'd like to ask her what
she thinks of humans or just how it
feels to be alive